i haven't seen confessions i mean either
i've never even heard of it confessions
is actually a japanese movie right
um i know and it's
it's the one movie
yeah yeah yeah i didn't know it was even
based on the book yeah but it's
probably my favorite revenge movie of
all time i think it's a miyabi
book is is the one where it's like set
in high school yeah with like two goals
kind of kind of think so so the concept
of this movie
um is uh the main character's a teacher
right yeah
and she used to teach uh teacher class
right and so these two students
from these class or i i think it's like
two or three students from this class
they basically uh they basically murder
her
uh her daughter yeah um but because of
japanese laws
if you're like a minor then you can't be
charged even if you've technically like
killed somebody right we're just [ __ ]
yeah yeah which of which is [ __ ] and
that's like the whole premise of this
movie
yeah and the premise of this movie is
just
her basically playing [ __ ] 5d chess
against these high schoolers
and just coming up with a very unique
like revenge
scheme against these kids right and it's
kind of it's kind of like
maybe similar to old boy if you've seen
old boy but maybe just
maybe just not as [ __ ] yeah i think uh
i i think that's pretty [ __ ]
yeah old voice over boy's pretty [ __ ]
and my problem with old boy is that as
far as old boy isn't on your throat well
my problem with old boys i really liked
it but there are definitely
some parts of old boy that really push
your
suspension of disbelief like like uh
without spoiling like without spawning
the ending of old boy or something
there's
some plot elements where you're just
like final twist yeah like the final
twist where you're just yeah
yeah the final twist where you're just
like
can you can i can the human mind be
tricked into doing this yeah
that's like kind of pushing it what i
like about confessions
is that it's kind of like the same kind
of deal where it's
one person look uh getting revenge over
people
yeah but it's just it's kind of like
she's kind of like a light yagami
lelouch kind of character where she it's
it's
a very it's very intricate eventually
but it's believable yeah and
it's it's i mean it's believable because
the whole premise is [ __ ] to begin
with because this is real like
you know japanese miners cannot be
charged even if they kill somebody and
that's that's like the premise of the
movie but
um the way it unravels is really
really interesting and um for a japanese
movie as well
one of the biggest things i remember
when watching this movie for the first
time
is that out of nowhere they start
playing radiohead
hell yeah and i'm just like is that a
[ __ ] radio head i'm listening to now
and so radiohead is positive
i'm so like literally one of the best
parts of this movie was just like you
know
like the the song for like the epic
reveal where she reveals everything yeah
it's just [ __ ] radiohead
and i'm just like this is this is the
best reveal i've ever seen in the movie
wait which radiohead song is it
um i can't remember it it's it's not a
face
remember the emotions i just remember
the emotions man it's not it's not the
most famous radiohead songs right
yeah it's it's it's the one movie that i
think it's like really underground
because it's a japanese movie uh and i
everyone who's watched it so far has
been really really [ __ ] impressed and
i don't see many people talking about
this movie because yeah
i feel like japanese cinema uh japanese
cinema in general just gets looked over
a lot but
i feel like because they tackle very
japanese things more often than not
the way they go about things is very
japanese and like kind of like doesn't
really make
well not that doesn't make sense but
kind of odd yeah there's a lot of like
cultural
elements and like things that they throw
back to that where other people feel
like oh that doesn't happen in my school
yeah you've kind of like just looked
past a lot of things i think when you
watch japanese movies or foreigners you
can't relate to most of the stuff yeah
yeah cause like i've i've definitely
read this book before and i really
really enjoyed like back in like high
school as well i think it's quite an old
book
but um yeah i mean for one i didn't even
know that this was like
a movie first of all yeah i didn't even
know it was available in english because
like a lot of japanese cinema
doesn't make it outside of japan but
like there's always translations online
oh yeah
of course but it's like i don't know i i
just wasn't expecting this yeah yeah
like i i recommend a lot of movies from
this director i can't remember his name
but confession is my favorite one
memories memories of matsuko is another
movie that this director made that
is like really underground even for like
japanese cinema but it's [ __ ] amazing
um but yeah just like if you if you're
going to take anything out of my 3x3
watch confessions because more people
need to know about confessions kokuhaku
um it's an amazing movie it's one of the
few japanese movies that
i think is just easily accessible to
like anyone you don't really need to
know about japanese culture
um it's just a good revenge plot and it
kind of if you like old boy or you know
a lot of korean movies
you're probably gonna like confessions
yeah miyabi miyuki i think is is the
original woman who wrote kokaku right
like
all of her books kind of like deal with
this kind of like yeah
it's kind of like criticizing [ __ ] up
parts of japan and like using it
as like an advantage right yeah yeah for
that that's really good yeah the bulk
armor
sounds really good yeah yeah might
actually watch it yeah um